(pensive music)
(spoon sliding)
- [Narrator] Phish Food, Chunky Monkey,
these quirky flavors are
unmistakably Ben & Jerry's.
But what really sets the brand apart
is its activism despite being owned
by one of the largest food
companies in the world.
- It's been really fascinating to see
that Ben & Jerry's has
really held their ground.
- [Narrator] Companies that take a stance
on social and political issues
are becoming more important to consumers.
According to research by
the polling firm Ipsos,
60% of consumers said
they would be more likely
to consider a brand that's aligned
with their own views.
So how does the company blend activism
into its business model?
This is The Economics of Ben & Jerry's.
- Ben & Jerry's really takes
a fairly liberal stance
on a lot of political issues.
And Ben & Jerry's has not shied away
from making those positions very public.
- [Narrator] The company's social mission
is rooted in the values
of its two founders,
and their life experience
having grown up in the 1960s.
- What's going on is genocide.
- [Narrator] Ben Cohen and
Jerry Greenfield founded
the company in Burlington,
Vermont in 1978.
Two years later, they were
selling pints to grocery stores.
And in the late '80s, they
began using their ice cream
to support social causes.
- They've spoken out about
how they were advised
by counterparts in the industry
that speaking out and taking
these activist positions
would hurt their bottom line.
This was just not something
that businesses were doing.
- [Narrator] But Ben
& Jerry's pushed ahead
and by 1999, it reported
$237 million in sales.
Today, the company says
the overwhelming majority
of its sales comes from
selling packaged ice cream
in supermarkets and convenience stores.
- What the company has
shown over the years
is that if your product is delicious,
is attractive in other ways to consumers,
you can do these things
and still be a successful business.
- Hi.
- Thanks so much.
- [Narrator] Ben & Jerry's
centered its business
on an idea it calls linked prosperity,
which means that has the company profits,
its communities should too.
So when Ben & Jerry's needed investors
to build its first
manufacturing facility in 1984,
it offered stock exclusively
to Vermont residents first
as a way to give back to the community
where it got its start.
A year later, the Ben &
Jerry's Foundation was born.
It received 7.5% of the
company's annual pre-tax profits
to fund community-oriented projects.
In 2000, multinational
food conglomerate Unilever
bought Ben & Jerry's for $326 million
but the ice cream maker negotiated a deal
where it could maintain
its own independent board of directors.
- While Unilever has made statements
over the years saying
that these are not the
issues of the whole company,
they have not been able
to stop Ben & Jerry's
from making statements on social media
that get a lot of attention
because of how controversial they are.
- [Narrator] After the killing
of George Floyd in 2020,
many companies started
posting on Instagram
to show their support for the
Black Lives Matter movement.
While Ben & Jerry's
released this statement,
saying "We must dismantle
white supremacy."
- They were so much more
direct than other companies
and that's where Ben & Jerry's
has continued to be different.
Because they've been
doing this for decades,
they have that credibility.
- We need to have people
sitting in at their Congress,
people's offices, at
their senators' offices
and telling 'em we ain't leaving
'til you pass a Green New Deal.
(people cheering)
- [Narrator] But these bold statements
haven't been without backlash.
For example, in 2021,
Ben & Jerry's announced
that it would stop selling its products
in Jewish settlements in the
Israeli-occupied West Bank
and contested east Jerusalem.
This decision was criticized
by Jewish communities
around the world.
- And I will give up on my Ben & Jerry
and everything that Unilever produces.
- [Narrator] And by Israeli politicians.
Two months later, several state funds sold
or threatened to sell their
investments in Unilever
accusing the company
of breaking state laws
that prohibit the boycott of Israel.
Unilever didn't respond
to requests for comment.
At the time, the company declined
to discuss the divestments
but reiterated its commitment to Israel.
In February, Ben & Jerry's posted
this tweet criticizing
President Biden's decision
to send US troops to Ukraine.
- Unilever CEO said Ben & Jerry's needs
to stay in their lane basically
and said that they should
not speak out about things
that they're not experts in.
- [Narrator] A spokesman
from Ben & Jerry's said,
"We don't believe one must
be a foreign policy expert
to promote the ideals of peace
and to oppose armed conflict
as a solution to solve problems."
(spoon banging)
In addition to its public statements,
the company's social justice initiatives
are also baked into every
aspect of it business model,
how the ice cream is made,
how it's packaged and how
it's served to consumers.
- There you are. No problem.
- Thank you, thank you very much.
- [Narrator] For example,
the brownies that are used
in flavors like Half Baked come
from a bakery in New York
that hires people who face
barriers to employment.
Ben & Jerry's also uses milk and cream
from family-owned dairy farms,
and all of its flavors
are fair trade certified
which guarantees that
farmers who grow vanilla,
cocoa and coffee beans get a fair price
for their harvest.
- There's a flavor that's
gonna be supporting
the Poor People's Campaign.
- [Narrator] For special edition flavors,
Ben & Jerry's often works
with nonprofit organizations.
- And a portion of the proceeds
will be donated to be
supporting the campaign.
- So it's a real influence,
not just with consumers
but also by using their profits
to give back to these organizations.
- Can I please have a Mint Chocolate.
- [Narrator] Ben & Jerry's also has
about 215 independently owned
scoop shops across the US.
As corporate activism
becomes more important
to consumers, we might see more
companies voice their social
and political stances online.
So does this mean it's the end
of an era for Ben & Jerry's?
A spokesman from the company says,
"Ben & Jerry's acts on
values it cares about
but trying to go at it solo
was never the intention."
(lively music)